[Musique]
salut laurie bonsoir à tous bonsoir à
tout l'événement sur les marches ce soir
c'est bien entendu la présence de
catherine deneuve venu présenter le team
d'emmanuelle bercot de son vivant avec
benoît magimel on a retrouvé toute
l'équipe du film ainsi que les invités
de ce festival qu'ils sont prestigieux
les marches c'est parti adèle exarque
aux poudres c'est en train de monter les
marches pour un film à la semaine de la
critique avant qu'on parle du samuel
benchetrit fier là l'émotion la force de
la réception du film de catherine
corsini la fracture comment vous avez
vécu tout ça c'est un grand moment
vraiment inoubliable est incroyable et
les gens adorent le film il se passe un
truc sur ce film là vous le sentez ouais
j'ai l'impression en tout cas hier
c'était vraiment
voilà on travaille en travaillant
travail et puis après il ya des moments
comme ça c'est hier le fils de catherine
corsini c'est un film dans l'air du
temps le film samuel benchetrit aussi
même si très différents a failli tirer
un parallèle entre les deux ce que
j'aime c'est des réalisateurs ou des
réalisatrices avec qui on justement une
vision du monde puissante qui me
qui m'interpelle qui me qui met pas qui
m'intéressent kekpart exactement la
mienne parce qu'on a chacun sa main mais
qui a une puissance qui fait que j'ai
envie d'y aller je m'ennuie pas que ça
me passionne
[Musique]
marion cotillard signe des autographes
rendait cette fille
et voilà la montée des marches marion
cotillard qui produit eager zone hausse
ce documentaire consacré aux ravages du
plastique en indonésie
[Musique]
pour voyager à benguigui et isabelle
adjani qui vont attaquer la montée des
marches soeur encore en salle ou
isabelle adjani à deux au xxe rachida
brakni et maïwenn isabelle adjani devant
les photographes avec yamina benguigui
est ce qu'il représente provocatrice
ma catherine deneuve représente bien sûr
la france bien sûr
je veux de la brillance de la france et
puis elle représente une des plus
grandes actrices du monde est aussi
l'une des femmes les plus libres les
plus drôles et les plus audacieuses que
je connaisse
[Musique]
vva
emmanuelle bercot vous présenter ce soir
de son vivant à ça a l'air d'un trafic
vraiment ludique à plein de niveaux
expliqué nous propose parce que c'est un
grand mélo et que c'est pas un jour qui
se fait si souvent que ça avec catherine
deneuve et benoît magimel et face à eux
un vrai médecin qui a un rôle aussi
important que et c'est la relation entre
ces trois personnages lisses en deux
films
[Musique]
on
c'est votre troisième film avec
emmanuelle bercot il ya quelque chose de
spécial quand vous êtes avec elle c'est
différent il ya quelque chose de
vraiment différent quand elle vous
dirige est ce que vous pouvez
l'expliquer c'est à dire qu'elle est
elle est particulière de de caractère
c'est quelqu'un qui a elle a évidemment
beaucoup de caractère même et très doux
et très ferme très exigeant et demande
beaucoup voilà elle à bout j'avais
beaucoup d'heures de route force et dans
celui là elle vous demande quelque chose
de très difficile c'est c'est un vrai
mélo en même temps ça va très très loin
c'est une vraie relation
elles demandent déjà au départ un
scénario qui est très bon rythme très
délicat et on sait que ça sera difficile
oui c'est ça revenir à cannes c'est un
bonheur pour vous voit
non je suis surtout contente que calais
plus et rouvrir et que le cinéma
que le cinéma ait pu rouvrir voilà et
qu'on est pour reprendre sa com comme
avant c'est vraiment émouvant pour moi
oui je laisse monter les marches
merci infiniment catherine deneuve y
était avec nous
[Musique]
là